hello and welcome to the show where we
invite people to come and talk about
their insights into this country and its
inhabitants our guests are always people
who come from somewhere else today it's
samia akika originally from algeria but
brought up in france samir is a
choreographer a director a curator and a
producer of contemporary dance and just
last year he was appointed the artistic
director of the dance theatre in bremen
that's a city in northern germany
actually welcome to the program first of
all actually i made up your title
because the other day when i telephoned
you and said what's your title you said
i don't have a title
but you're the boss aren't you
uh kind of i don't know we are we are
it's two of us actually
but i'm in charge of in bremen i'm in
charge of uh doing choreographies
for the state theater there exactly yeah
and is that choreographies for the just
for dance shows or do you do
choreography in theater pieces as well
until now since it's my first year over
there and
we just do our own work
but there is uh rumors that i might have
to do to help them out for some musical
i don't know here i think i don't know
and you'll have to do the choreography
that's what i heard uh yeah yeah
do you
do you fancy having a go at hair
uh no i i don't really uh
i don't really enjoy musicals but i'm
not specialist i'm gonna be in trouble
it's gonna if we're going to talk about
musicals i'm not no i wasn't okay i
didn't i had no idea that you you were
going to do this i was just uh asking i
wondered whether it'd be interesting to
do something with non-dancers
um
yeah what i work uh
i also worked with non-dancers i worked
with kids for example i worked with
street people um
had i mean as we're gonna talk about it
i guess uh i worked with all kind of
people not only skilled dancers
is germany do you think a good place for
contemporary dance
absolutely
um
well i i started dance because i saw a
video of pinabash choreography right
yeah the great german choreographer yeah
exactly and um
yeah i decided to
follow kind of her footstep and i heard
about her school what is considered her
school even even if it's not her school
but that's where she studies at and what
she got uh
her uh
the base of her work from this
folk one joshua in essen
and many uh dancers of her company was
teaching there
that's how i end up in in germany and
for dance and for to to um
try to reach her company as a dancer you
actually you actually came to dance
quite late for a dancer really we'll
talk about that a bit later
you say germany's good for contemporary
dance what about german audiences are
they
a knowledgeable audience do you think
are they a good audience um i have the
feeling well i come from a family where
we didn't have any cultural activities
we never went to a theater or
concerts or whatever or like um yeah
vernissage or anything like that
but uh what i noticed here it's i have a
feeling that people still go in theater
in germany that's one one aspect and
second i found that still there is still
public money to support art in in
germany
so i think we are very privileged in
germany actually and i'm very thankful
that i um
came to germany and i got support
what i notice um
in the dance pieces i've seen of yours
obviously i've done some research is
there's a lot of humor
in them and um
in the past i personally have thought
that a lot of
modern dances is perhaps
too pompous but yours isn't am i right
thinking that do you like a lot of humor
in it
well maybe it's a trick that i use
to gain audience maybe maybe that's the
easy way but it's also
i hate artists who take themselves too
seriously
and uh
i just hope i keep my feet on the ground
and you more is helping me and to do so
also working with children for example
or
working with older people
seniors it also gives you perspective
yeah i just want to stay grounded and
say stay the way i am
no matter what good time bad times and
you use the audience sometimes in your
shows or or certainly the dancers going
into the audience and things yeah or
yeah we depends on the shows we
it's
i mean i try not to repeat myself maybe
i have a style or i have a
print a trademark i don't know about
that
but yeah sometimes we do depends of the
ideas that comes out
i have no rules and that's the point
it's good to play to know rules um
what the audience expect what is
supposed to be what is supposed to be a
performance and just to
bend the rules and be on the edge it's
always interesting i find perhaps you've
uh answered my next question but i'll
still ask it your company is called
unusual symptoms
is that because of no rules or is that
has it another reason
uh you gotta find cool names first of
all and uh
i don't know if this is a cool name uh
like when i go uh abroad uh we are
called the unusual simpsons because not
so many people know the word same thing
so unusual simpsons instead of unusual
so i'm not sure
our names are so cool actually well
actually i think if you're called
unusual simpsons you people you might be
sold out you know
who knows who knows yeah yeah okay let's
see some unusual symptoms now
and this isn't a medical program sami
akika uh work with his dancers in
freeman
and my guest is samia akika and i
actually i i thought when i saw that
report that it was all a bit of ironic
about the golf but
now i've met you this is serious the
golf is
becoming a bigger thing in your life
than dance or
yeah i wish that's the that's the idea i
have in the back of my mind but
it's a long-term quest
who knows
i'm working on it yeah yeah absolutely
well professional golfers can play till
they're i don't know 60.
there is a champions tour afterwards so
yeah there is no no limits actually and
you play in bremen then as often as
possible or whatever wherever you are
exactly really exactly do you take your
clubs with you that's the problem it's
not that easy with airlines but i try to
have always won at least with me my
beloved sandwich 26th yeah
and have you got what's it called um
oh what's i'm not a golfer as you could
tell have you got a uh
you know the number you have if you
you're over there
handicap oh thank you samia thank you do
you have a handicap no no i wait uh
to be more stable in my life to uh to do
all that yeah because i travel too much
and uh
yeah let's see if i settle down then i
will uh
belong to i will join a golf club it's
uh investment so um
we should get back to the dance i guess
unfortunately i'm very intrigued by the
music in in in the shows that i've seen
how important is music in your shows i
mean does the music sometimes
um come first
i don't know
well
could be that i have some like
kind of a playlist where i save some
some songs that i wish to use or
but not really i i don't know
with us things comes organically so it's
not i don't really have a plan and
but the best is to work with a live
musician so um that's what i try to do
it's not always possible
so uh
you can use music in a traditional way
to just uh
that the dance match the music kind of
or you can use it as a contrast or
you have more an abstract relationship
with the sound or
i don't know we i can use uh soundscape
also uh depends what's the goal and what
kind of atmosphere you want to develop
no we had iggy pop yeah um
because i i i did a piece called funny
how this year and i thought
let's quote a little bit the
the punk attitude uh like people going
in public spaces and just having fun
and um so i thought
that would be a good idea to uh to bring
the
old goodies
such as iggy pop
and your dancers um
to me i mean i'll just show a picture
here if i can find this yeah
let me show you this picture this is
some of your dances from one of you i
mean they don't
appear to be sort of classic
i know not classical it's contemporary
dance but don't appear to be dancers how
do you choose them because they seem to
have to do
lots of things music singing sometimes
as well yeah well this this is a piece
called me and my mom that we
i thought it was time for us
to kind of
investigate our relationship with our
mother
and
so
the lady in the back
she's not a dancer obviously
she's a musician and she's one of the
mother of the performer
the guy on the left is pablo he's a
great musician he's opera singer i mean
he graduated from the same school as i
did but he's a
wild guy and he likes to perform so i
use everybody
as a
companion and try to push the limits of
their uh extend a bit their talent and
their the possibility i i don't
necessarily uh enjoy that people are
perfect on stage i like to see uh
uh
people so with their flaws and their
expertise also
and another quick picture
do you i mean you're the choreographer
but do you do the makeup as well
i would not say so but in in that case
that girl is called sriatlana she's from
novosibirsk in siberia and she had this
boring traditional haircut and um
but she got so much into the project you
see she shaved half of her
hair
and uh
which just
made her a little bit more glamorous and
uh more sexy and fine
so i was just helping her i guess i
commented on the color she chose for her
lipstick or something i don't know
i just helped her out your dancers
though in bremen come from all over the
world it seems they're really a mix is
that important
or is it just
really
that's the one i want that's the one i
want it doesn't matter where they come
from the dancers in bremen are the
people who
you see when i got this offer to work in
bremen i've decided to not do an
audition and work and take back the
people who've been supporting me all
these years
so
they are who they are and they are the
mostly people from
the school of icing
and the school of sn is a very
international school so we have
italians we have people from costa rica
from cuba
germany also finland
myself half algerian half french
we are a mix and i've been always in
this kind of surrounding um
nationality doesn't matter so much to me
culture i found interesting and uh
i don't know i don't have enough
distance to to really answer we are like
a family we know each other for many
years and i have a big circle of artists
that i work with for um all this time
and
i just enjoy it but
i believe in everybody so you know i
could work with you robin and enjoy i'm
sure you haven't seen me dancing
that's very kind of you say you
mentioned your algerian french your
dad's algerian no no yes yes your dad's
algeria and your mom's throat um but you
were born in algeria
yes and when did when did you come to
france when it was very early must have
been when i was like four years old so
we can say that paris is really
where you're from yeah
of paris yes
um
you also mentioned to me that on
you kind of a double culture what do you
mean by that do you mean algerian french
or
yes french
german i don't know yeah yeah it's true
but no nationality i i
yeah from from my family i would say
algeria and france for sure
but now i live for about 15 years
even more actually in germany so that's
also
part of me now yeah the german culture
what was what did you think of germany i
mean germany
germany is france's big neighbor
did what did you think of germany
growing up in france i'm gonna bring up
some cliches you know what i'm sorry but
yeah like
my my um the father
of my uh
mom
my grandpa was
anti-german because of the war so if i'm
honest
she she wanted to have german boyfriends
on holidays and when they went on
holidays and he was like very uh very
angry at that
and uh
in france there used to be this big
cliche and
i mean a lot of efforts have been doing
by the politics also that
peace
comes and but it's true that when i come
back to uh to france and i tell people
that i live in germany i know they have
kind of a
strange reaction still to this day yeah
i would say so
they will they will say
why germany it's a little bit uh
yeah they will say they will see only
the negative aspect of the german
culture like being not so flexible be
too organized and
i mean the stuff we know yeah but uh
they don't see do you have a different
opinion now absolutely yeah absolutely
but it's true to android germany it's
better to know the system
so i i panic myself when i have anything
to do with the administration since i
cannot read german i'm really in trouble
so i feel still handicapped but whenever
i know how things works
if i have to book my ticket now in the
train station then i know it's going to
work and i will have the exact seats
that i want to have and so on and i
won't have that surprise but just the
trick is to understand how it works and
when you when you are just wondering
when you go back to france do you say to
people actually it's not all the cliches
they're actually okay yeah for sure i
feel the ambassador of germany now oh
yeah yeah absolutely and and also france
has tendency to to be very self-centered
and they still think they are the center
of the world especially in art and
my opinion whatever that
the value of my opinion is uh it's very
boring what they do in france
and uh yeah and i try to to to
open the mind of people for sure
but that feeling i don't have when i go
somewhere else in the world especially
when i go far away um
people have a high opinion on on germany
maybe because of the cars i don't
let's just find out about coming to
dance because i mentioned earlier you
came late you
you were studied physics and mathematics
and then sports and sports yeah indeed
you you're a very good basketball player
i was yeah yeah yeah i know golf's your
passion now but is it were you nearly a
a professional basketball player but i
tried i tried to that's why i went to
the states i tried to
yeah and to to get a scholarship to play
a basketball in university that didn't
work but that's a boring story it's more
an administrative uh
i came with the wrong visa kind of
then you came back and then i came back
then i had to uh
yeah i was the oldest son of the family
and my dad was worried that i
don't get a proper education so i got a
lot of pressure to study so i went to
university i was not so bad in hard
science so
i got
after two years you get an exam in
france in the university and i passed
that and i had to join the army for one
year at that time it was uh obligatory
and then i uh i had the balls to
confrontate myself to the family and say
i don't want that kind of life um
let me choose my future
you know and uh so i joined the sports
university
i didn't picture myself as a teacher uh
because i'm too passionate about it and
uh
i knew that i would be frustrated
because i was a coach also
and i know that i don't like when there
are limits to my work
i like to feel free and to go
you're a kind of coach now kind of yeah
yeah yeah and i did a lot of summer
camps with kids when uh when i was
students
and all this i think i use it to
you have to be to have some psychology
when you are a choreographer i think it
depends what you want to do but i don't
want to be the kind of guy who has a who
is very strict and and show people what
to do and and be that's not who i am
i um
that's one of the first thing i told
myself and i have to refresh my myself
once in a while but i think when you
decide to do something you have to stick
to who you are and accept your uh use
your personality uh that's the best
chance you have to to be
to be happy about the results so i use
my coaching skills um
in choreography also but also as a
manager of a group
well you've got quite a body of work so
far you're keeping busy to say the least
here's some clips uh of some of my
guests samia akiko's works
very narrow interpretation
questioning the advantages and
disadvantages of adult life that was the
theme of extended teenage era a
production from 2007.
samir akika explores each performer's
individual vocabulary of expression
their respective biographies memories
designs for life and ideas for the
future
my accent shifts like high-speed clouds
me and my mum a production of akiko's
dance label unusual symptoms in 2010
took a strange look at the mother image
the continents of neighborhoods
traversable by tubes the high pitch
unconditional love disappointed
expectations and unrequited affection
the performing artists reflect and enact
their own relationships with their
mothers
bringing back their own childhood and
youth reaction shared by millions my ex
like millions more had her borders well
defined
akika dedicated the play to the mother
of german dance theater pina bausch who
was a great inspiration for him
in 2011 akika worked with eight young
people from belgium and germany eight
perspectives on society and living
within it
young and furious is a typical
production for samir akika it's nothing
more or less than exploring life asking
questions and making statements
to
everybody
that we
want
to
respect
ourselves
and my guest is the choreographer
something
you just told me that the guy in the
middle there with the
head was a cook in a fast food
restaurant yeah and how did you find him
uh
by
by chance
by chance but i mean did you were you in
were you getting food off him or uh no
no um
we had like a partner in belgium and
somebody didn't show up
and they just asked that guy to to
replace him
and uh that was my luck
his
taste is his name and he's a very
talented young guy and did he
dance before or no
never how did you see his talent
he's a genius he he can
he has great ideas he's very creative he
can write poetry he can
play drums he can sing so good um
and he has instinct and
and i love that i love instinct is a big
thing then for for all of your
performers yeah and also he need that
because he doesn't have sk skills like
he's not trained dancer but he knows how
to get the the public in his pocket i
don't know if you can say that in
english yeah yeah yeah get the public in
your pocket even if you can't i
understand i'm sure everybody will
understand that yeah yeah i know he's
such a charming guy and uh
and yeah and he has just a good reflex
on stage when something goes wrong
he
he just has the right comments like he's
a specialist into uh uh
developing a very uh um intimate
relationship with the public
i mean when you're developing a show
that may be two hours long and i don't
know which i don't know in the beginning
how long it's going to be exactly
well that's kind of what i was going to
ask you but i i mean
how much do you when you start
rehearsals yeah
do you have no you have must have some
idea
and how much is formed in your head i
have a desire i have i have a desire
let's let's uh
let's have fun
and that's it and then i don't know and
then with the time then uh this this
idea matured in my head and peop and we
do some brainstorming and we see what
comes and uh i put people in situation i
ask questions
but we don't have a script and that's
that's a very interesting question i
find because working this way in a state
it's very problematic
theater yeah because we don't have
i don't know how the stage should look
like i don't know what i need uh
forehead and they want to prepare i give
you the freedom
it's a struggle uh it's uh because the
other artists work in a different way
they they have a concept uh before they
have a book where they start from they
have a piece of work where they start
from so they can develop a whole concept
and
our our way of working is developed day
by day on i rely
a lot on what
my partners give me
i put them in situation i ask questions
and i adapt myself to what comes out
what gave you this idea
uh
it's a commercial uh a commercial uh
that we found on youtube i think um
it's uh so i saw him this this dancer
yeah well this panda coming on stage
with the popcorn yeah and he goes and
sits in the order yeah he's a nasty
panda and we thought yeah yeah that's
the that's the whole idea he's very uh
a very mean guy and uh that's kind of
funny because you have the cute image of
the cute panda and he's actually very
cruel in a nice way still with you more
yeah that's the stupid uh tony's walk um
yeah
what else to say
yes
yeah crossing but
yeah we
lots of images lots of images one one
one more and i wanted to include this
because this uh you've actually have a
stand-up comedian exactly one of your
shows that's the cooker but now he has a
perfect
that's why you don't recognize him yeah
yeah so he didn't realize that was him
no he was really good yeah and he wrote
the the monologue no yeah yeah he's
awesome i show him some ideas i i show
him an uh
um
excerpt from a movie um maybe you saw it
with de niro and jerry lewis king of
comedy yeah okay yeah the king of comedy
yeah why you saying about in
it's a struggle with the theater to to
have complete freedom they do give you a
lot of freedom i wonder
how do they write the notes in in in in
in the leaflet that people get
to see your shows
because they have to write that in
advance but they don't know what the
show is going to be about i mean you
just don't seem to know it yeah that's a
struggle we have always so i i try to
outsmart them and write something that
is pretty vague but pretend to say
something
so that i buy myself some time
because i don't know how
i should start next next august next
september i should start the new
production
i don't know how i would feel uh by uh
then you know what would be my
priorities in like what would be my
worries and i try um
it's very hard for me to uh
to anticipate what i would be uh
preoccupied with one thing you've done
outside of the theater in bremen you've
worked a lot over the years with the
goethe
institute tell us a little bit about
that because presumably you don't you
have to prepare that in advance or don't
you know what you're doing there
i
don't necessarily know especially with
the gutter because you you
you don't know where you land i mean
they send you all over the world i
should say for example before going to
nigeria
i had no idea about nigeria except the
football team
you know
and so
i try to spend a lot of time in the
street to spend a lot of time with the
people i will work with to see where
they live what is the
to have a glimpse of of what's what's
happening there what what what are the
struggles what are these taboos what are
the
yeah what
what people have to deal with what what
i found interesting and uh what they
need to
i try to challenge people basically so
in every way possible
so i don't really have a plan uh
sometimes i do but i would change anyway
i would adapt myself um
so but my my main goal is to do
something that they are proud of and
that they can identify with and not
having a colonial
attitude like i show you what's done in
the west
of course i am who i am and i have the
education that i have and there is a bit
of it but i try to uh to show them that
they they have it all inside them and
that's the point that
i'm trying to launch a rocket
kind of like that they
that's very inspiring
and uh it gave it give me a
long-term friendship all over the world
and it's it's very beautiful it connects
us
well we talk about your latest project
because i know you've just come back
from siberia in a minute but right now
samir's adopted hometown of bremen has a
rich cultural heritage one thing that
illustrates this is the old brothers
grim fairy tale of a donkey a dog a cat
and a rooster who all passed their prime
in life set off to bremen to become
musicians
even the bremen town musicians from
grimm's fairy tale and their reasons for
wanting to come here
the atmosphere in bremen is almost fairy
tale-like at the foot of saint peter's
cathedral with the over 600 year old
landmark the statue of hollande and the
vasa renaissance style town hall which
was made a unesco world heritage site in
2004
the upper story of the town hall
showcases bremen's former wealth
sculptor hans j muller has lived in
bremen for more than 30 years
what's special about the town hall is
that it's still exactly as it was when
it was built it didn't suffer any war
damage nothing
i think it's the last town hall in this
style that's really completely undamaged
and original
bremen's ostatoa district is where the
action is
it was built in the latter part of the
19th century
and it has lots of pumps and shops
the visa book museum hosts exhibitions
of all the latest developments in art
established in 1991 it was europe's
first private collectors museum
modern works of international renown are
shown here
in 2007 the building had some forty
thousand visitors
museum director carsten ahrens enjoys
these unique art objects
the citizens naturally get very involved
a lot of what happens here especially
culturally has come about through their
commitment and we take the same approach
in working with private collections
but for those who prefer things more
traditional the schnau is the place to
be
this medieval quarter is the oldest part
of bremen
the houses are all lined up in a row as
if strung together hence the low german
name schnoor or rope
the schnozcontour or trading post is in
a building dating to 1630.
it sells a traditional bremen product
tea
and it offers a real northern german tea
ceremony
with rock candy known as cluntius and
bremen
and fresh cream which should swirl in
the cup like a cloud
the point is to drink through the
surface to the sweetness in the bottom
raymond has something to suit all tastes
and many are simply loathe to ever leave
the city
my friends my wife are all fed up
because even after 30 years in bremen i
say that i'm only here temporarily and i
believe it
though this state could last until the
end of my days
at night the city shows its romantic
side
bremen a unique city with hanseatic
charm
my guest samia akika also lives works in
raymond but
i wonder if do you feel like that art is
there is that their 30 years and he
fears he's only temporarily there do you
feel
you're temporarily there or do you feel
settled there
well when i look back at my life i've
been uh
i turned so many pages so i have no idea
i feel good right now but
i have no idea you lift the present yeah
yeah yeah
you were recently in siberia and um
you you you
you came back
i just think just a few days ago and you
did um very kindly send us some pictures
of the show now we've got a
we've got one of the performers here
dasha yeah and looks to me as though
she's got a broken arm yes she does she
has
happened in general rehearsal um she had
to uh she had a quick exit and a quick
entrance
and uh the
cleaning woman just uh
the floor was wet and that girl didn't
know and she ran back on stage and
slipped
and broke her arm and continued the show
and continued the show yes she did and
yeah it was very sad because she didn't
deserve to she worked so hard like she
was
the one that was less killed for dance
and she really worked so hard to uh
get somewhere
and the poor one and just be just before
the show she broke her arm but
nevertheless she did all the
performances and we use her new handicap
to um make it uh as a bonus
um another picture because this doesn't
look like a dance show
but a girl on a trapeze that's valeria
um
that's pole dance
in russia yeah in russia uh women do a
lot of pole dance yeah for uh
i i thought paul dance was just
belonging to a strip
three places but actually uh
i've been attending classes it's very uh
it
demands a lot of fit to be really fit
and uh it's very acrobatic and she did a
lot of gymnastics when she was young
that's why she could do it so well she's
um
what was the show about actually what
was that
i mean our id because i just told you
about how conceptual i am but we wanted
to talk about the city called
novosibirsk
which is i will take just 10 seconds to
explain you that it's important they the
tsar the last car i think it was when
they wanted to build a train across
russia um orient express yeah yeah yeah
uh
had to cross that river and um
and all the cities around uh wanted to
have the the train passing by because
they got that that would be a
a big push for the city but that
engineer didn't was not corrupted guy
and he decided to
to cross that river right there and
that's they had this city is very is
very young it's very fresh it's one of
the fastest
city a growing city in the world
it's called nova cbs it's the capital
city of siberia
so
that was a starting point like the
bridge the train the train station
in that city it's also a city where
people don't stay actually it's a it's a
passage uh
people just don't want to transit that's
why we call it uh norway uh transfer
novo transfer yes
and will you are you going to continue
to work with the goethe are you allowed
to with the work at the time
in bremen if i managed to do both then
i'm allowed to yeah
but i hope to because that's very
essential to me it's uh i consider it as
a big privilege to be uh
invited by the gut institute all over
the world to do great projects such as
this one it was really an amazing
project
a lot of people cried a lot it was very
emotional uh work and i think it was a
little uh cultural revolution uh yeah
but they do a project they do great work
around the world um the goethe suit they
they're possibly best known for teaching
the german language but there's a lot
more as a cultural
institution they are the best in the
world
samir has been great talking to you
thanks very much for being with us
he says thanks to my guest summit akika
and thanks to you for watching if you'd
like to comment on the show write to us
at insight dw dot d e we always like to
hear from you i'll be back at the same
time next week with another guest on
insight germany until then bye-bye
you